We're asked to solve for x.
And we have 9x squared minus
42x, plus 29 is equal to
negative 20.
Now, you might be tempted
immediately to try to factor
the left-hand side of this
equation to get the product of
two binomials, and that they
equal negative 20.
But if you think about
it, that's not
going to help you much.
That product of two binomials
is only useful if they're
equal to 0.
Then you can say, well, one
or both of them need
to be equal to 0.
But you can't make any statement
like that if they
both equal negative 20.
So the first thing we want to do
here is not to factor this
left-hand side, but to make sure
that we have a quadratic
equation equaling 0.
We want a 0 on one side
of this equation.
And the best way I can think of
doing that is just to add
20 to both sides of
this equation.
So if we add 20 to both sides of
this equation, then we are
left with, on the left-hand
side, 9x squared minus 42x,
plus 49 is equal to 0.
Now we have a quadratic
expression equaling 0.
Now we have a nice quadratic
equation, and we can factor
this thing on the
left-hand side.
Now we could factor it by
grouping, but something might
immediately pop out at you.
And when you see numbers
like 9 and 49,
those are perfect squares.
So maybe this whole expression
is a perfect
square of some binomial.
So let's think about
it a little bit.
9 squared is 3x squared.
And 49 is 7 squared, or
negative 7 squared.
And let's see, negative
42-- 3 times 7 is 21.
21 times 2 is positive 42.
But if we make this a negative
7, because negative 7 would
also work, negative 7
squared is also 49.
Then 3 times negative 7,
times 2 is negative 42.
Let me write that down.
42 is 2 times 3, times
negative 7.
So this fits the pattern
of a perfect square.
So the left-hand side of this
equation, right here, we can
write it as 3x minus 7-- we
can write it as 3x minus 7
times 3x minus 7, or just
3x minus 7 squared.
And that is going to
be equal to 0.
Now, we essentially only have
one expression equaling 0,
times itself.
So the only way that's going to
be equal to 0, is if that
expression is equal to 0.
3x minus 7 needs to
be equal to 0.
And now we can just
solve for x.
Let's add 7 to both sides of
this equation, and we get 3x,
these cancel out,
is equal to 7.
Divide both sides by 3, and we
get x is equal to 7 thirds.
x is equal to-- let me just
write it here-- x is
equal to 7 over 3.